[Musique]
là c'est un livre de contes de paul paul
il a jamais fait de dessins essais
inscrits cette année pour la première
fois paul et ses petits camarades ont
réalisé leurs contes illustrés à
guyancourt
pendant un an les élèves ont eu carte
blanche pour écrire leur histoire
peintures pastels au feutre à chaque pas
son style
un travail guidé par marina schwarz j'ai
voulu les faire travailler sur l'art
imaginaire vraiment qu'ils développent
qui s'exprime en créant leur propre
conte fantastique
l'idée d'utiliser le conte fantastique
souvent inconsciemment les comptes
permettent de révéler beaucoup de chose
de soi
donc c'était important pour moi de les
connaître sinon leur part propre
personnalité en vue pas d'âge pour
s'exposer adultes et enfants tous
partagent la fiche de cette sortie
d'atelier au programme une découverte de
leur production de l'année
le mois de juin consacré à la mise en
valeur des artistes en herbe guyancourt
toi une tradition pour la ville un but
en cours on a une vraie chasse avec tous
les habitants et on a des artistes au
nez donc c'est bien effectivement tous
ceux qui ont enduit de d'exposer et bien
on leur donne cette possibilité et on
voit des choses extraordinaires
des travaux mais aussi des animations à
découvrir jusqu'au 3 juillet tissage de
papier carnet de voyage création d'une
oeuvre collective en argile de quoi
susciter peut-être de futures vocations
[Musique]